good evening Stephen markman was
appointed justice of the Michigan
Supreme Court in 1999 and re-elected in
two thousand and two thousand four prior
to that he served as judge on the
Michigan Court of Appeals he has
practiced law with the firm of Miller
Campfield patek and stone in Detroit and
and from nineteen eighty nine to
nineteen ninety-three he served as the
United States attorney in m'sia as
United States Attorney he was
responsible for one of his largest
federal prosecutors offices in the
nation and received national attention
for his efforts in combating violent
street crime and public corruption prior
to this justice markman served for four
years as the assistant attorney general
of the united states after being
nominated by President Reagan and
confirmed by this US Senate in that
position he headed the Justice
Department's Office of Legal policy
which served as the principal policy
development office within the department
and which coordinated the federal
judicial selection process prior to this
he served as chief counsel of the United
States Senate Subcommittee on the
Constitution and as deputy chief counsel
of the United States Senate Judiciary
Committee for seven years justice
markman has authored scholarly articles
for such publications as the stanford
law review the University of Chicago Law
Review the University of Michigan
Journal of law firm from American
criminal justice law review and a heart
journal of law and
policy he is also served as a
contributing editor national view review
amazing since 1993 justice markman has
taught constitutional law at Hillsdale
College as a distinguished visiting
professor in political science tonight
justice markman will explain the idea of
the 21st century Constitution he will
explain what it's it's what it means to
the enduring principles of our
Constitution and how we might better
address these matters in our judicial
confirmation process please join me in
welcoming Justice Stephen markman well
thank you very much it was much nicer
introduction when i receive not too long
ago when i was introduced by the master
of ceremonies as being one of the finest
judges that money could buy I think he
was trying to say something nice and
he's not sure he heard my wife was with
me as a very gently was introduced by
the same master of ceremonies as being
one of the finest ladies to walk the
streets and I think she was similarly
similarly perplexed by the introduction
so thank you very much i I'm grateful I
would like to talk about my aunt evening
constitutional non debates and I very
much
questions insights that you might have
because the great composers still trying
to develop the topic so he was
extraordinary this year with two
vacancies on the state Supreme Court but
as David indicated David Bob indicated
as assistant attorney general under
President Reagan I prepared a report for
the Attorney General entitled the
Constitution in the year 2000 choices
ahead this report sought to identify a
range of areas in which significant
constitutional controversy could be
expected over 20 years by preparing this
report I sought to provide a glimpse of
the stakes involved in the then ongoing
public debates over federal judicial
selection in competing understandings of
the proper role of the judiciary and
they also sought to identify what I call
Forks in the road that will determine
the changing councillors American
constitutionalism the controversy is
identified in constitution year 2000 as
important as I think they were haulin
significance before the controversies
that I think will almost certainly rise
over the next several decades for those
of us I assume there's at least a few in
the river within a traditional
constitutionalism to James Madison's
Constitution the resolution of these
emerging controversies will determine
whether the Constitution of 2030 bears
any resemblance to the constitution of
the Reagan years much less to the
Constitution that guided this nation for
most of its first two centuries it is
critical that those who are committed to
preserving our traditional Constitution
understand clearly the nature of the
upcoming litigate of offensive by
proponents of life Oliver's
Constitution there is nothing that such
components would like more than to
transform beyond recognition and with
the minimum of nelson public attention a
constitution that served this country
during the eighteenth nineteenth and
twentieth centuries to render the United
States the freest the most prosperous
and the most creative nation is you the
world if there's an overarching theme to
what proponents of the 21st century
Constitution wish to achieve is the
mention of the democratic and
representative processes of American
government it is the replacement of a
system of republican self-government
with the system of judicial government
in which substantive policy outcomes are
increasingly determined by unaccountable
federal judges rather than merely
defining broad rules of the game for the
legislative and executive branches of
government the new constitution would
compel specific outcomes yes there would
remain the forms of the founders
constitution that bicameral legislature
the periodic elections the states but
the most important decisions those
determining the nature and direction of
the continuing American experiment and
liberty and self-rule would increasingly
be undertaken by courts especially by
federal courts populated by lawyers and
black robes lawyers serving lifetime
tenures and lawyers unencumbered by the
messiness of having to persuade
constituencies or the representatives of
other constituencies of the wisdom of
their ideas concerning the role of
government these courts would be unbored
in any serious way from the language
that we the people had placed in their
constitution and informed instead by the
perspectives of a legal profession whose
self interests are ever more distinct
from the productive sector and by
international elite opinion and by
creative and innovative legal academics
it will be I submit the California
referendum process written national
assessed by which the decisions of
millions of voters on matters such as
racial quotas social services funding
and immigration policy have been
routinely overturned by a single judge
acting in the name of the Constitution a
constitution that not only would have
been unrecognizable to its creators but
unrecognizable to all the past
generations of judges who have ever sat
on the courts of this land if 21st
century constitutionalism prevails there
will be no accompanying public debate at
least not one in which ordinary citizens
will have any effective voice there will
be no public debate over the
transformation of the constitution and
once it has been transformed there will
be no public debate over countless
matters of policy that are now routinely
the subject of hearings negotiations
compromises and give and take within the
representative process rather such
debate will be short-circuited by the
decisions of judges acting on behalf of
a constitution for our time a modern
constitution on the living Constitution
resemblance sadly the Constitution's of
pay and crippled nations across the
world to constitutional revolutionaries
of termina part of our century
contemplative America transformed not a
curing body equivalent of the
lincoln-douglas debates not as a result
of any landmark votes of those whom the
people elected to represent their values
not really considering judgments of the
electorate and not by any series of
transformative elections but by a
decision of five lawyers on the Supreme
Court in a handful of others serving on
the lower federal judiciary the adoption
of the 21st century Constitution will
occur not through high profile Court
decisions resolving grand disputes of
Warren peece abortion capital punishment
or the place of religious values in
public life but more likely it will
occur as a result of decisions resolving
utterly forget
and mundane disputes the kind mentioned
on page a 11 of our daily newspapers if
at all for it is the legal principles
and precepts of 21st century
constitutionalism that will prove so
destructive to our values and once these
values and precepts have been
incorporated into the supreme law of the
land they were then be insinuating into
our daily lives through countless
decisions to safe I hope it's acting
upon these newly established precedents
they ingrained or institutionalized you
know well before the addresses and
begins to appreciate the consequences We
the People will then establish this
constitution and we wish we the people
have become your relatives let me
provide am I just a brief summary of
several more popular theories by which
advocates of the 21st century
Constitution hope to transform the
founders constitution in particular i
hope to touch these thoughts ordinary
citizens so that thinking that so that
they can be made that are aware the
states while judges and lawyers maybe is
custodian the Constitution's document as
the heritage of every American citizen
first of all is the privileges or
immunities Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendments since shortly after the Civil
War the privileges or immunities Clause
has been understood as protecting
citizens from a very limited array
rights that are function of their
federal citizenship such as the right to
be heard the courts of justice and ready
to diplomatic protection in defining the
protections of the
they're immunities clause in this way
the Supreme Court in the slaughterhouse
cases rejected the argument that the
clause also protects rights that are
function of state citizenship asserting
that this would be the federal courts
serving as a perpetual sensor over state
local governments Mortimer's result
other language of the 14th amendment
authorizing the Congress to enforce its
provisions the courting slaughterhouse
also indicated as concerns that the
privileges or immunities clause was
intended to bring within Congress
Congress's authority the entire domain
of powers along the exclusively to the
states thus the slaughterhouse cases
asserted one very long sandy foundation
of American federalism now all that in
sort of a degree of medical judicial
authorities alternative then she go to
the states and slaughterhouse who
interpretations of the Due Process
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment many
proponents of 21st century have found it
awkward to pursue the substantive review
of state local laws under constitutional
provision that is Gary only toward
ensuring compliance with fair procedures
thus the long-standing interest of such
components in refashioning the criticism
movies cause as the new bill rights
within the Fourteenth Amendment it is
seen as a strength of the privileges or
immunities clause that there are no
established
us as to what rights would be
encompassed within its terms the
practical consequences of abroad
privileges or immunities clause with
each authorized signer judges to embark
on far more impressive review group of
state local decision-making and thereby
to impose a blowout and celta firing
infirmary on the state's professor
Goodwin ruler of the University of
California for example has suggested
that at a minimum the privileges or
immunities Clause stands for the
proposition that all citizens enjoy
subsidy rights essential to realizing
what he calls as equal seeing the
national political community and that
when the courts and Congress may
determine what civil and political
rights and what social economic
entitlements are necessary to make
national citizenship meaningful and
effective this is no standard at all in
to the extent it gives meaning to the
privileges or immunities Clause it would
ensure that whatever Mata come of
federalism remains extent right now
considerably less will remain tomorrow
all state laws and all local laws will
be subject then to substantive review by
federal courts issue number 2 positive
rights these these are arcane concepts
many of these but these are the building
blocks upon which the new constitution
is going to be built in unless ordinary
citizens understand these issues we are
not going to win in the courtrooms of
the classrooms of the land positive
rights for the 21st century
constitutionalist perhaps as I say the
greatest virtue to redefining the
privileges or immunities Clause is the
prospect of transforming the
Constitution from what they view is an
archaic 18th century guarantor of
negative liberties into a genuinely
contemporary charter of affirmative
government
guaranteeing individuals an array of
positive constitutional rights these are
all their terms as president Obama has
observed in his criticism of the legacy
of the Warren Court it never ventured
into the issues of the redistribution of
wealth and if more basic issues of
political and economic justice and
society the Warren court simply wasn't
that radical it didn't break free from
the essential constraints that were
placed by the founding fathers in the
Constitution that generally the
Constitution is a charter of negative
liberties says what the states can't do
to you says what's what the federal
government can t do to you but doesn't
say what the federal government or state
government must do on your behalf so
says the president and I believe
President Obama is correct the
constitution of the founding fathers
unlike most modern constitutions does
define individual rights and negative
terms in terms of what the government
cannot do to you the government for
example cannot inflict upon you cruel
and unusual punishment and therefore you
have a constitutional and individual
right not to be subject to such
punishment the government cannot engage
in unreasonable searches and seizures
and therefore again you have a
constitution or individual right not to
be subject to such seizures and so forth
constitutional rights are defined in
terms of what remains after governmental
overreaching has been prohibited by
contrast unlike the typical third world
Constitution ours does not afford
affirmative welfare state rights to
material goods such as housing education
food clothing a job or health care
rights in which there is a correlative
obligation upon the state to obtain the
resources from other citizens to pay for
these rights that is if there's a
constitutional right to free health care
then there's a constitutional obligation
on the part of government to raise
revenues
to pay for such healthcare proponents of
the 21st century Constitution have many
grievances with the individual rights
premises of our current constitution the
procedural focus of the Due Process
Clause with its old-fashioned conception
of individual rights as those relating
to life liberty and property and the
negative cast of the very few
specifically defined Rights of the Bill
of Rights these each post significant
barriers to what 21st century
constitutionalist hope to achieve in
reconfiguring America the privileges or
immunities clause on the other hand
suffers from none of these infirmities
best of all it is ill-defined and easily
susceptible by definition to definition
by judges more or less at their own
discretion in short in the words of
Professor Balkan of the Yale Law School
there would be nothing left of the
founders to fetish sighs as various 21st
century Constitution advocates have
urged a privilege or immunity might
become anything pertaining to equal
opportunity or basic rights it might
encompass any social or universal right
or it might be construed to guarantee
social or economic equality these again
are all their terms and however pleasing
these turns of phrase there should be no
mistake each of these each of these
terms will supplant representative
decision-making with the decision making
of unelected unaccountable in life
tenured judges all those one set of our
Constitution that it does not enact
Herbert Spencer's concept of lays a
faire capitalism we will soon see
whether it does today enact a European
welfare state or even a more rigid form
of socialism if the 21st century
constitutional view prevails ours will
be a min America defined by a
constitution in which citizens are
entitled to what is possess
by their neighbors in which economic
redistribution has become as ingrained
principle as federalism in the
separation of powers in which the great
constitutional controversies of the day
will focus upon whether port should be
subsidized in housing allowances
subsidized at eighty-nine percent or
ninety-four percent of the last fiscal
year level and in which a succession of
new rights will be parceled out to the
people when they are deemed worthy by
the successes to our founding fathers on
the bench in short it will be a
constitution no longer informed by an
18th century Declaration of Independence
but by a 21st century declaration of
dependence third there's a concept of
state action a barrier posed by both by
the due process and privileges and
immunities clause and viewed as
anachronistic by proponents of the 21st
century Constitution is the requirement
of state action as a precondition for
the enforcement of constitutional rights
and in the civil rights cases another
Civil War precedent the Supreme Court
asserted that the Fourteenth Amendment
prohibited only the abridgement of each
individual rights by the state they said
it is state action of a particular
character that is prohibited the
wrongful act of an individual is simply
a private wrong and if not sanctioned in
some way by the states we're not done
under state authority the individuals
rights remain in full force however for
advocates of a 21st century
constitutionalism if fairness and equity
as they perceive these are to be
achieved the Constitution must become
more like a general legal code
applicable indistinguishably to matters
public and private Fourteenth Amendment
claims of due process and equal
protection and privileges and immunities
must be applied to private institutions
as they now apply exclusively to state
institutions consider for example an
institute
that you may have heard about that
within the last few minutes Hillsdale
College despite being the embodiment of
a thoroughly private institution
government officials have sought to
justify the imposition of federal rules
and regulations upon Hillsdale by
characterizing it as the equivalent of a
state entity on the grounds that have
received public grants and aid when in
response to this argument and in order
to retain its independence Hills
rejected further grants-in-aid the
government then sought to justify its
rules and regulations on the grounds
that Hillsdale was the indirect
beneficiary of grants and AIDS going to
individual students such as GI benefits
once again in response to this rationale
Hillsdale asserted its independence by
disallowing its students from receiving
public grants even those earned as in
the case of GI benefits and instead
bolstered its own scholarship resources
we have thus witnessed a steadily more
aggressive effort by government
regulators to treat a variety of private
institutions as the equivalent of the
state in there by to extend the reach of
the Fourteenth Amendment however it'd be
so much more convenient simply to
nullify the state action requirement all
together and that is what's proposed
professor Mark tush net of Harvard Law
School instructs us times have changed
and that he would overrule the civil
rights cases he says the state
requirement doctrine contributes nothing
but in clarity to constitutional
analysis it works as a boogeyman because
it appeals to a vague libertarian sense
that Americans have about the proper
relationship between themselves and
government it seems to suggest that
there is some domain of freedom onto
which the Constitution doesn't reach we
would be well rid of the doctrine
now professor tush net succeeds in this
mission hillsdale's policies concerning
such things as tuition diversity
admissions curriculum multiculturalism
affirmative action and discipline will
each have to pass the scrutiny and
receive the imprimatur of judges fourth
is the concept of political questions in
areas that once viewed is entirely
inappropriate for judicial involvement
federal courts have begun to assert
themselves in an unprecedented ly
aggressive manner the limited role for
example of the judiciary with regard to
matters of national defense and foreign
policy is not explicitly set forth in
the Constitution but from time
immemorial it has been understood that
matters of defense and foreign policy
were non justiciability exclusive
responsibility of the elected
accountable branches of government that
is the Constitution's judicial power
which is the only power that courts can
exercise has always been understood to
require deference to the judgments of
popular branches as far back as Marbury
vs. Madison in 1803 Chief Justice
Marshall recognized that questions in
their nature political can never be made
in this court yet just since the year
2000 just since the beginning of this
century the court has arrogated unto
itself in a series of 524 decisions
Authority concerning the treatment of
captured enemy combatants overruling in
the process contrary determinations made
by both the legislative and executive
branches most notably the court ruled in
boom alien vs. bush that foreign
nationals captured in combat and held
outside the United States by the
military as prisoners of war a war
authorized by the Congress and waged by
the president's commander-in-chief and
such individuals possess the
constitutional right to challenge their
detention zin federal courts
Dustin yet one more realm of public
policy one is to which the sovereignty
and liberty of a free people are most
dependent national defense judges have
now began to begun to embark upon a
sharply expanded role the Supreme Court
is bestowed under the Constitution
rights upon enemy combatants who
previously enjoyed none it is overturned
the decisions of the president in the
process it has transformed the
Constitution's apportionment of powers
by asserting the print
commander-in-chief's Authority may
require what it calls the vindication of
judges and the court has established an
ongoing role of federal judges in
devising procedures by which the
judicial review of military detention
decisions can meaningfully be carried
out if there is no realm of political
questions left areas in which the courts
are going to deter to other branches or
other decision-makers if there are no
longer any traditional limitations upon
the exercise of the judicial power then
every matter coming before every
president every Congress every governor
every legislature and every County
Commission and city council can with no
difficulty at all be recast as a joose
tisha bill dispute or case or
controversy and if that occurs every
policy debate taking place within
government at every level will
eventually become little more than a
prelude for court resolution number 5 is
the concept of the Ninth Amendment this
is another looming constitutional
battleground the meaning of the Ninth
Amendment to the Constitution many 21st
century constitutionalists view the
amendment is communicating that there's
some unknown array of unenumerated
rights that lie fallow in the
Constitution waiting only to be
unearthed by farsighted judges applying
their own conceptions of natural justice
professor Thomas Gray of the Stanford
Law School stated for example
that the ninth amendment constitutes a
license to courts to look beyond the
substantive commands of the
constitutional text to protect
fundamental rights not expressed therein
rights of abortion for example
contraception and homosexual behavior
and similar sexual privacy rights have
already been imposed by judges detecting
such rights in the Ninth Amendment
however in the words of justices potter
stewart Hugo black this understanding
turn somersaults with history and would
render the court a day to day
constitutional convention instead the
more conventional understanding of the
DeMint has viewed as viewed it always in
historical context of the Bill of Rights
of which it is part by this traditional
understanding the Ninth Amendment was
simply designed to dispel any
implication that by the specification of
particular rights in the Bill of Rights
the people had relinquished to the
federal government's rights not
specified or enumerated it was well
understood by framers such as Madison
Hamilton that the guarantees of the Bill
of Rights merely comprised a partial
enumeration of rights reserved to the
people with the remainder of the rights
to be enforced by the states or left to
the people the Ninth Amendment like the
10th amendment was adopted to emphasize
that our national government is one of
limited powers its purpose was to avoid
an implied extension of federal power
the Ninth Amendment authorizes courts to
declare unconstitutional acts of
Congress that exceed its limited
authority even where such acts do not
contravene a specific provision of the
bill of rights as Justice Anthony
Kennedy is written the Ninth Amendment
expresses a recognition of state
sovereignty and of the role of states
and defining human rights it is not an
open-ended grant of judicial authority
and ink blot in judge Bork's terms
allow federal judges to transform a
statement of limited constitutional
government into a warrant for unlimited
government 6 concept is transnationalism
professor harold koh now State
Department legal counsel is perhaps the
leading proponent of what he describes
as transnationalism he compares this
with what he describes as the
Nationalists philosophy that is somehow
taken hold of American law for the past
two hundred and twenty years he says
trans nationalists tend to believe in
the political and economic
interdependence of nations while
nationalists focus instead on preserving
United States autonomy the trans
nationalists recognize that
international domestic law are merging
into a hybrid body of transnational law
while nationalists preserve a rigid
division between domestic and foreign
law trans nationalists believe that the
mesta courts have a role to play in
incorporating international law into
domestic law while nationalists complain
that only the political branches are
authorized to domesticate international
legal norms professor Co remember the
council the legal counsel at the State
Department now predicted the clash
between competing visions of
constitutional laws he describes them
between transnationalism and nationalism
will play out in future Supreme Court
confirmation hearings and that these
will be pivotal in determining by the
year twenty twenty the direction which
the United States's states law proceeds
he says what the United States in the
world will look like if we just let
constitutional change happen and what it
will look like if we seize this moment
to push our constitutionalism and our
policies and better directions will be
at stake in the next few Supreme Court
confirmations in practice
transnationalism would legitimize
reliance by American judges upon foreign
law in giving meaning to the United
States Constitution you would bind
federal and state governments to
international treaties and agreements
that had never been ratified by the
United States much less enacted into law
by Congress it would render both the
domestic and international conduct of
the u.s. increasingly beholden to the
review and judgment of international
tribution tribunals and Geneva and The
Hague it would expose American soldiers
and elected leaders to the sanctions of
international law for imagined war
crimes and violations of the earth and
would once again replace the judgments
of officials representing the American
people in holding paramount the interest
of the United States of America with the
judgments of European bureaucrats in
multinational panels of judges finally
and precisely balancing the interests of
this country with the interest of
authoritarians and dictators throughout
the world in conclusion President Obama
has stated what matters on the Supreme
Court is those five percent of cases
that are truly difficult in those cases
adherence to precedent and rules of
construction interpretation will only
get you to the 25th mile of the marathon
that last mile can only be determined on
the basis of a judge's deepest values
core concerns and broader perspectives
on how the world works and the breadth
of his or her empathy now if the 21st
century Constitution prevails there will
be a far higher figure than five percent
of cases as to which nothing would
matter more than a judge's deepest
values core concerns and breadth of
empathy judges would be making more
decisions and they would be making more
decisions in which the law would only
get you through the 25th mile if indeed
it got judges anywhere close to that for
the central value of 21st century
constitutionalism is not the
Constitution but the judge and
with the intention of generating debates
and providing a brief roadmap to the
constitutional forks in the road that
will soon be facing our nation that I
offer these thoughts well there's never
been a time in our history at which
there was not some serious
constitutional debate within our people
I respectfully suggest that there have
been few times at which this debate was
more stark and more fundamental in
defining the American experiment thank
you very much
let's take questions for a few minutes
and I really do look forward to your
thoughts and I'll try to respond as best
as I can does anybody have any thoughts
your insights now what can be done to
stop this trend that's for the next
speech actually I've written lengthier
remarks that develop these subjects a
little bit more precisely and these are
going to be published by the Kirby sent
center on their site and a monograph
produced and in those I have a number of
recommendations concerning the
procedures of the Senate Judiciary
Committee in holding its confirmations
but most of all what I want to do by
working with Hillsdale College in the
kirby center is communicate the groups
of people who may not be part of the
inside the inner constitutional sanctum
what is at stake right now so hopefully
there will be more interest communicated
to their elected officials and
eventually the elected officials
particularly those in the United States
Senate can participate in this process
might take an interest in trying to
focus the confirmation hearings on these
matters I mean have been many very
disappointing confirmation hearings in
the past I thought the one with regard
to justice Sotomayor was actually a good
step in the right direction but i think
we continue to have to encourage members
of the Senate to devote even more focus
to constitutional issues I guess most of
all what I'd like in the confirmation
process would be an increasing focus not
just on judge Smith or Judge Jones who's
actually before the committee but I wish
these would be used increasingly as an
opportunity to assess the health of the
Constitution and to analyze the the
great constitutional debates of the time
to try to inquire of judicial nominees
what they think about these issues I
think there's a real Miss on
standing on the part of many senators as
to what constitutes an appropriate kind
of inquiry and many people have a lot of
confusion about that I think it's all
together appropriate to ask questions
about how judicial candidate proposes to
resolve a constitutional dispute that is
what they would look to what the
evidence that they believe would be
appropriate to consider in that process
I don't believe its proper to ask how
would you decide a particular precise
case in the future but i do believe its
proper to ask them questions about
larger constitutional controversies what
do you think about a colorblind
constitution this has been a matter of
debate in the United States for the past
30 years what do you think about a
colorblind constitution what do you
think about the debate that Professor
Code defines between the Nationals from
the trans nationalists I think these are
proper entirely proper debates now the
advice and consent process is the choke
point of our constitutional process once
a judge judicial nominee gets beyond
that choke point he's on the bench for
the rest of his life I think it's
entirely proper for senators I'm talking
about senators of both parties inquiring
of judicial nominees of both parties
it's entirely proper to inquire just
what kind of custodian a judicial
nominee will become if he is blessed
with this opportunity to define our
Constitution for the rest of his or her
life and I don't think senators need to
be apologetic about that I think they
need to understand this is one of the
most important responsibilities that
they carry out especially those on the
Senate Judiciary Committee yes sir in
the back
thank you discuss a little bit to
Congress's ability to restrict the
jurisdiction of the court and recent
experience in that area I'm sorry
Congress's ability to restrict the
jurisdiction of the court and recent
experiences in that exercise apart well
that's that's a significant
constitutional issue people don't always
agree article 3 section 2 of the
Constitution gives Congress the right to
limit the appellate jurisdiction of the
Supreme Court it was done most famously
in a post-civil war during a
reconstruction era case in which the
Congress attempted to limit the courts
exercise of certain habeas corpus rights
directed towards some of the southern
Confederate rebels and the Supreme Court
said you and the Congress have the right
to do this and therefore we can't
continue to hear those cases so on the
one constitutional challenge that we've
actually heard to that precept the court
said Congress does have this Authority
how regularly is here and he and i
served in the Justice Department and you
remember the early 1980s when Attorney
General William Prince myth broached the
idea of doing this with regard to issues
like abortion school prayer and school
busing it was a great deal of
controversy he's initiative eventually
didn't go anywhere and they didn't go
anywhere at least in part because there
is some discomfort level on the part of
some senators about the proposition of
limiting the jurisdiction of courts
they're not quite sure how far they can
go and I think you used to be a lot more
education lot more discussions to what
the wrath of that right is
important provision of the Constitution
apparently he's arguably designed to be
one of the more significant checks and
balances upon the court but it just
hasn't served that way since members of
Congress have not been willing to try to
challenge judicial authority than that
way but the one time it was done it was
upheld by the Court so it is a it's a
very very interesting precedent see
first of all you referred to Professor
Liu in Berkeley you know I just learned
that today I mean I was really quite a
quite interested to hear that in the
longer paper that i have i quote from
Professor Liu on several occasions he's
giving me just the right quotes for my
analysis in a number of different areas
I quoted from him once today of course
but I think that'll be an
extraordinarily interesting nomination
professor Liu is very much a part of the
community that I've tried to describe
today and I've spoken with them a number
of offices not urging any particular
action on this nomination I'm not I'm
not involved in a particular nomination
controversy but I think I expect there
would be a lot of questioning of the
candidate based upon the kind of lines
that i'm introducing here I don't know
professor Liu I don't know its
credentials I know some of his thoughts
on the Constitution so I'm not urging
any particular course of action but I
think it'll probably be almost certainly
an opportunity in which some of the
elements of what constitutes 21st
century constitutionalism will be
ventilated and I would very much look
forward to seeing what happens at that
time
are you talking about how hard this
might be to undo them so that these
things happen we've got some somewhere
tell me why he comes to the Senators and
other people would be excited any
judgments cool oh she likes head will
they have an opportunity to rinse back
to and then sir that's a very very good
question you know what I think about
when you asked that question it really
hits it a core matter here is that I'm
going to be speaking at the Federalist
Society this weekend in Philadelphia and
the subject of my panel is originalism
and precedent I guess it all depends on
what kind of decisions are articulated
by the 21st century constitutionalist
but even more it depends on what the
successor President appoints in terms of
more traditional constitutionalist are
these going to be traditional
constitutionalist who will typically
defer to precedent in which case we
would preserved what has occurred under
the 21st century constitutional regime
or will it be judges whose priority is
to restore what they view as an original
astonished and about the Constitution
means I mean this is an ongoing debate
and you'll find interpretivist or
original astore textualist whatever you
want to call them or constitutional
conservatives some of whom do place an
emphasis on regard and respect for
precedent in others of whom say no the
oath of office that judges take is not
to judge under court said 10 years ago
over the Constitution says so
okay that's the decision to determine
whether that was going to be undone for
sympathy more he played music utilizing
rating in law you know like that so many
years many conservative the book upon
execution on statutory interpretation is
somewhat of a ratchet theory as I heard
you make precedent red impala pressman
too many conservatives were content what
the Muslims process were initiated by a
justice covers do acknowledge those
presidency sustain those precedents you
envision decade revision a sense that
kind of rats are you sure that imagine
never worse direction we can never
restore a responsible sense of
constitutionalism so I guess in addition
to the debate over the 21st century
constitutionalism what you're asking L
is how is the debate going to be
conducted within the conservative
community between those whose priority
of starry decisis or precedent and those
whose priority is trying to restore what
they understood Madison placed in its
constitution and I've mentioned Madison
several times or by the way I'm father
Constitution understand that but it's
not just Madison Constitution that we're
talking about it longer we're talking
about Mickey's Constitution as well as a
constitution that week and gave us was a
constitution interpreted within a matter
of just a few years by the united states
supreme court in that today is a
constitution that's under channel all
that our constitutions on your channel
it's not just a man sewing and
constitution of 1789 is also the
ammonium constitution of the 1860s we
are talking about a transformation
constitution that is literally without
precedent in our nation's history and
it's photo constitutions that are at
stake not just a constitution in 18th
century but also the reserve see how
would you compare the transformations i
can say that of the least dangerous
branch how does mean government to the
world that already exists the
administrative state that's emerging
within the european commission well
we're seeing the transformation of the
united states by the administrative
state to and it used to be the case that
you couldn't delegate where it is right
or authority outside of tigers course we
all know today that the administrative
branches of government may fire more
fire more
during a very very hard stuff during
entire Center when I went to Europe to
the governmental develops and government
adults men's a year ago the best
generation to battle proposed orchestra
at all I guess I see a further advance
development while during his historic
rise here in the United States I see
government becoming increasingly distant
from you people I see the people's
attitudes and views increasingly
relevant and I see a government in which
there is not the the traditional sense
of whose consent has to be given to the
government and the food responsible for
governing that new tradition I had in
the United States right how is it going
these are capital punishment i'm going
to use unhelpful punishment III people
in the united states and people in
Europe isn't all that different
significant majorities in both countries
favor capital punishment yet we in the
united states have a majority of states
two-thirds of the states that have
adopted that policy because they are
still reflective and responsive to the
views of their people whereas countries
like france germany
exactly the same way the government
institutions bilberry underselling what
is responsive is that you in the United
States oh I don't pretend that that's
we're going to end up no vote another
country's history so it so far but I
hope you see a tendency there that I am
afraid to move in court in United States
he's very good question too yes sir I'm
wondering to pick an elaborate on the
privileges or immunities clause and you
talked about at the beginning if I
interpreted you correctly which I may
have not it sounded like you agreed with
the decision in slaughterhouse and I'm
aware that there are those that argue
that the reconstruction Congress has
actually meant to enforce provide some
enforcement for the natural rights of
african-americans so not some open-ended
Clause but actually inductive natural
rights and i think justice Thomas's even
expressed interest or sympathy towards
resuscitating the clause can you
elaborate on that yeah that too is a
good question I don't pretend that all
the issues I've talked about today have
drawn a consensus of support from every
judicial conservative there are some
differences there are for example some
judicial conservatives who'd like to
take advantage of the unidentified
rights in the Ninth Amendment I mean we
all have our favored rights there's lots
of Rights that I'd love to impose on the
Constitution if I could do that and I
would respectfully disagree with those
people who want to use the Constitution
to attain their own favored rights as
much as I might personally like their
favorite rights in the end I think the
most important right we have is the
right to select our representatives and
to determine the course of our
government and I think that's better
achieved when we when we elect members
of the legislature than when we have
judges making these decisions for us
even when the decisions happen to be
good decisions concerning the privileges
are
munities claws you're correct again
there that there is a debate and if
you'd be interested in my more detail
positive glass sharing with you I've
seen justices how Justin stomach
Thomas's comments I don't know that it
goes so far as to say these anything a
hospitality was just in the if you like
the look at it more closely I've looked
at that history for what its when I
don't think that history is clear all I
served on many stands for the
proposition all natural life we were
conferred on people who had callers in
fact I don't want persuaded that I still
be concerned about the clause because
even though i'm sure you have a very
elevated sense of national rice I'm sure
most of people rise judicial activists
and those people who are part of this
21st century community also talked the
terms of natural rights I mean you can
get 10 people together and get 10
different conceptions of natural rights
so I think it's a practical matter if
that concept of the privileges or
immunities Clause becomes part of the
Constitution in the year 2012 you are
not going to find the advocates of this
new right looking to see what Madison
might have thought about it or what
Lincoln might have thought about it they
are going to be looking upon it largely
as an empty shell in which they and
their colleagues on the bench can you
give can give meaning through which they
can get me into it so I think you need
to look at that practicality but
legislators Virginia's of new Attorney
General Ken Cuccinelli recent recently
was one of three our state's attorney
generals who filed suit against EPA over
its so-called endangerment finding he
action filed to zoos or one suit simply
had to do with challenging the the
scientific basis on which the EPA made a
decision and asked EPA to reconsider the
decision in light of the leaked emails
and what have you but it's the second
one not that I found interesting he and
II filed suit against DPA under what he
referred to as the double delegation
doctrine namely that the Congress had
unconstitutionally delegated its
lawmaking Authority to an administrative
body EPA and that EPA in turn had
unconstitutionally delegated its
rulemaking authority to a foreign entity
namely the UN's internet in a metal
panel on climate change and the splendid
climate research unit at East Anglia
University saying that both of those
institutions being non American
institutions were the recipients of this
double of what he referred to as a
second part of the delegation I'll be
interested in your thoughts on that
thank you well of course I don't know
the details of that particular lawsuit I
mean the only constitutional decision I
know that focused on this so called
double delegation doctrine was the
schecter poultry case during the New
Deal on which the Congress granted
authority to regulate industries and
industry by industry basis to the
Congress and the Congress in turn
delegated that authority to a year
the Congress delegated to the the
executive branch in the ni NRA then
delegated it to industry-wide
commissions in this case of poultry
Commission to basically make rules about
that that industry the prices the
supplies all other regulatory matters
relating to that industry and the court
said that that was an improper double
delegation but that was a different
court in a different era and I'm not
sure that the delegation of the non
delegation doctrine of the Supreme Court
before Roosevelt made his many
appointments to change the direction of
the court really is controlling anymore
there's been virtually no non delegation
cases that have been decided since then
and there have been a number of cases
that have indicated increasingly that
creative kinds of separation of powers
institutions like the special prosecutor
and the Sentencing Commission and things
of that such are consistent with our
constitutional system I don't have any
idea what the court would do this is a
delegation from the Congress to the EPA
and then from the EPA to a United
Nations board is that right i I just
don't have any idea what a court that a
number of occasions has said that the
separation of powers has to be viewed as
a flexible institution an institution
that has to be given breathing room an
institution that has to be allowed so
long as it doesn't fundamentally distort
the separation of powers I just don't
know what a court would say about that
was very good question what do you think
would say about it not what it ought to
say about but what do you think the
court would say about Anna
quetta god this is you because out of
all people la da that allowed EPA to say
talk about that three court in which it
said that EPA could regulate man-made
greenhouses get greenhouse gases as a
pollutant under the Clean Air Act it
seems to me all other bizarre decision
particularly if you concern yourself
with the Clean Air Act and realize that
whatever else one may say about it it
was not designed to deal with anything
even remotely resembling a man-made
greenhouse gases well never never mind
the double delegation the single
delegation is troubling enough here I
mean here you have the head of the
Congress for the last year and a half
talking about cap-and-trade legislation
and you know whether now we're going to
be able to adopt something along those
lines and all of a sudden the EPA says
well you know never mind we're going to
enact rules and regulations concerning
carbon emissions under what standards
and traditionally delegation from the
the Congress to the executive branch has
been justified to the extent that there
were some clear standards that those
standards have been thought to be the
only thing to transform and essentially
make a delegation of legislative
authority to into effectively an
executive delegation but again the court
has increasingly said the standards
don't have to be much you know if you
delegate something to the Civil
Aeronautics Board you tell them to
regulate the airline industry consistent
with the public interest that's a good
enough standard does that provide any
guidance to the ca va or the ICC or OSHA
morenia of the FCC or any other agency
as to what they need to do on a
day-to-day basis and deciding rules and
regulations not really but nonetheless
that's been thought to survive the
Constitution's separation of powers and
the non delegation so never mind the
second delegation I don't know how the
first delegation gets done yes sir this
will be our final question
since we're in a little bit of a
speculative area mash you speculate on
something that might help us with the
judicial ratchet to the left and
hopefully there hold it in line or pull
it back it has been posited by some
friends of mine and when looking to
instigate some angst among the at least
a Ninth Circuit if not the entire
federal judiciary that we propound an
act dealing with the Judicial Conduct
and one of the one of the specular
things has been to just codify the
grounds upon which any judge has ever
been impeached at the federal level and
input one additional section in there to
say if you made amend the Constitution
sir you mean that amend the Constitution
sir pass an act through the Congress
just codifying that under these grounds
historically judges have been impeached
for these reasons and they shall be good
good reasons under which if a judge
worked it could conduct himself him or
herself in such a manner they would be
subject to impeachment and add one
additional ground that being that if
they were to make a ruling not based
upon the Constitution or laws the United
States but upon some foreign
Constitution or non-government
organization that they were there
thereunto also subject themselves
possibly to impeachment might that have
just the passage of such an act if we
could get it signed certainly not by
this president but passed by the
Congress and enacted might that have a
salutary effect upon some cognitive
abilities for some of these more
far-ranging decisions that are emanating
from penumbra's of foreign constitutions
and the infield e to foreign concept
where there's lots of the numbers from
our constitution to one needn't go to on
bolivia as a few / numbers here too I
guess my short answer is I'm not sure
because Constitution allows impeachment
for high crimes and misdemeanors I don't
think without amending the Constitution
you could add to that standard frankly
you could subtract from that standard I
think high crimes and misdemeanors is
the definition it's the standard and
again I don't think unless you use the
article 5 process to amend it you could
change that standard now what are high
crimes and misdemeanors mean many of you
who recall President Ford's famous
statement when he was actually the house
minority leader and he was seeking to
have justice Douglas impeached he was
asked for what his high crimes and
misdemeanors mean to you means to me
whatever a majority of the Congress is
prepared to remove a judge for in the
sense that is about as good a definition
of high crimes and misdemeanors as we
have we know that it doesn't have to be
a crime or a felony as best as I think
we can understand from looking at the
history of high crimes and misdemeanors
which is a phrase that preceded the
Constitution it means corruption corrupt
behavior so on the one hand I don't
think you can change the definition of
what the Constitution currently says but
if you're sitting if you're elected to
the Congress the house or the Senate and
you feel that to rely upon the law of
another land where you're the custodian
of this constitution is improper and
verging on corrupt I don't know that you
couldn't you couldn't make such a
decision on your own but I think that
would have to be an individual choice on
the basis of 535 members of Congress I
mean this concept that we could look to
the law of other lands I mean it's
always been understood in the sense that
you know nobody wants to artificially
close off the kind of evidence that a
judge will look to and figure out what
the impact of a policy might be but
we're now at the point of giving foreign
law really practical effect in defining
our Constitution which i think is a much
different concept and that's one of
these many questions I think would be
perfectly appropriate to ask a judicial
nominee not just a Supreme Court nominee
but we ought to focus on
or court nominees as well you know what
do you think about the idea of defining
article 16 of Clause 2 of the
Constitution by what they've done in
Romania do you think it makes sense I
think it's perfectly appropriate and
that's part of what I like to see
achieved by introducing some of these
issues more aggressively into the advice
and consent debate